so now I will bow my hand I'm going to
come over to the dark side the days of
the Triwizard Tournament may be long
behind us but there's still so much to
explore behind the scenes like the magic
that went into making a bunch of awkward
teenagers look like they can dance
[Applause]
[Music]
number one at least the twins didn't
need to use a doubling charm
s up
[Applause]
if I look at the right bloke it's hard
enough keeping the twins straight when
they're not hidden behind beards and
wild hair now it's just downright
impossible sometimes as a director it's
easier to just show the actors what you
mean rather than try and explain it it's
just too bad he showed the wrong twin
kidding maybe you know when you
shouldn't break a director's rib
number two the Practical elements really
Elevate the viewing experience dragons
that's the first task I'm a cat of the
Dragon was made with a 14-foot wingspan
and later the model was scanned to
create a CG version of it ask your five
volt accio Firebolt yeah Harry
definitely conjured the wrong thing that
first time whoops he's probably just
exhausted from all the physical work
let's be real very challenging uh
physical endurance test number three we
wonder how bad the burns were one of the
most dangerous stunts Radcliffe had to
do was slide down the side of a building
he slid 40 freaking feet like 40
freaking times okay maybe not 40 times
but at least three that was really scary
anymore but we'll be scared I'm
convincing number four Ron and
McGonagall sitting in a tree to dance is
to let the body
Breeze Professor McGonagall has the best
advice we would have her as our dance
teacher any day inside every girl a
secret swollen Slumbers longing to burst
off and take flight a true poet and like
Maggie Smith teaching Rupert to dance
while hanging out in her robes is just
hilarious I had to try to teach Rupert
did downfield and that was pretty
strenuous do you think they actually let
her teach him or do you think this was
just a rehearsal when we came off the
set roof it was like he just looked at
said don't say anything number five
while Hermione was having her Cinderella
moment Emma was most definitely not her
dress went through a ton of designs and
alterations she was terrified she
damaged it I would not sit in it I would
not walk in it I would not do anything
in it apart from what I had to do in it
that didn't help any because I got down
about three steps and fell down in front
of the whole set Daniel Radcliffe always
thought Emma was beautiful and was
confused about Hermione's whole
Cinderella transformation moment Emma
was never ugly Dan was also a klutz but
that wasn't totally his fault I only had
about four days to learn because I was
doing another scene he made so many
mistakes during filming that they
decided to just capture footage of him
from the waist up I got to about halfway
through and then I would kind of just
lose it completely honestly that's
relatable what I like about Harris he's
pathetic at the whole romance thing he's
rubbish number six no amount of prep
would make these actors elegant it's the
best set I've seen so far I think the
description in the book was that the
ball was an ice palace we always
imagined prom would look something like
this did yours let us know in the
comments the whole thing of course
looked like Swarovski Crystal and was
stunning Professor mcgonagall's dance
lessons must not have paid off none of
us had a clue what we were doing
the secret is even as adults none of us
have any clue how life works I'm afraid
of falling or something and everybody
turn around pointing along remember how
Emma Watson once admitted to having a
little crush on Tom Felton no practice
just going straight into it lucky man
lucky man
Tom must have reciprocated it just
winging it must have been a joke because
seconds before the director was showing
them what to do I'd like to be able to
dance but I just don't
want to learn if you know what I mean
that's okay there's always the mosh pit
so yeah that'll be the first time you're
seeing a mosh pit at Hogwarts number
seven this may be the most CGI Harry
Potter ever used out of the water the
Giant pool is surrounded by green
screens to light up the tank they used
dozens of fluorescent tubes that shown
on the outside of the tank so that it
would glow on the inside and inside of
the tank the entire thing is one giant
20-foot pool surrounded by blue screens
the underwater environment that was
created almost entirely from CGI was
inspired by a Scottish lock the CGI mer
people were designed to look mythical
but getting them to look creepy took
work in order to make it look like
Daniel was acting off of something there
were two divers in blue suits grabbing
at him Radcliffe spent roughly 42 hours
underwater filming he did scuba training
for six months and six weeks were spent
filming we're not sure we could handle
that much water we obviously wanted to
get as much practice in as possible for
the underwater stuff number eight Gilly
weed is only one part of Dan's
transformation an hour and a half was
dedicated to applying Dan's silicone
Prosthetics they needed to be extra
secure to survive the underwater climate
number nine if only they could capture
every shot they needed in one take they
had underwater sanctuaries in place that
Daniel could use to slip in for a minute
and just take a good breath so that he
didn't have to come back up to the
surface it had both windows and a
chimney there were 20 people on the
diving team helping Daniel out once he
accidentally gave the wrong signal to
the dive team that meant this means
quick I've drown and get me up to the
surface whereas to me that means hey I'm
fine the entire team was in a flurry to
help him out oopsie Dan had to record
his lines after filming in a tiny bucket
with an underwater microphone
communicating with Radcliffe underwater
was tough they'd have to talk through a
chain of people and it slowed up the
process immensely after all the work he
went through you know what thanks he got
he wound up with two ear infections from
all his time spent underwater the actor
who plays Victor Crum was terrified of
deep water to get over his fear he would
work on his anxiety in the shower we
know what you're thinking huh he was
allowing the water coming from the
shower head to overwhelm him so that he
could practice being in the tank Robert
Pattinson struggled too because he would
get disoriented underwater not knowing
which way was up end of a long hard day
I'm off number 10 start the effects and
action Pattinson isn't being attacked by
living Vines of course but he is being
dragged back by a cord that switched out
for a Vine in the following shot these
are all the wounds from being attacked
by the magical hedge we can always count
on Robert to demystify the experience
for us magical hedge the Hedge was 25 to
40 feet high and the path only 5 five
feet wide to make it feel super
claustrophobic some game huh
some game number 11 and now here comes
the moment we waited four movies for
Voldemort's big reveal he wore one
prosthetic to cover up his eyebrows and
the rest was done with CGI in the books
Voldemort had red eyes but that was
changed in the movies because humans are
scarier than monsters true story without
the music to set the tone Voldemort
kinda comes off as comedic
hey
[Music]
number 12 we are dedicating an entire
spot to Robert Pattinson being
man this sure does look like it hurts
but that one they had to be like a coil
I had to get hit in my groin
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire is
definitely one of our favorites in the
series what's your favorite movie from
the series let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things